- My next guest is no joke one
of the hottest musical stars
on the actual planet right now.
She is one quarter of the
K-pop supergroup, BLACKPINK,
and her first solo track "On the Ground"
has topped the iTunes charts
in more than 50 countries.
And she has over 37 million
Instagram followers.
So, okay.
Give it up for Rosé, everybody!
(Kelly claps)
(sting music)
- Hi, Kelly!
- Oh my gosh!
Okay, I have to start with this, Rosé.
I've never been cooler to
my niece than this moment
right now.
She is such a huge fan of yours.
She actually legit
introduced me to your music.
I was like, "Oh my God, I love this!"
"I would chill with this."
And we were listening
to y'all at my house.
So anyway, I know that
you're a Korean pop star
but you didn't grow up
necessarily in Korea, right?
- Yeah.
I was born in New Zealand
and I grew up in Australia.
- That's such an interesting background.
I love- I love New Zealand and Australia,
by the way, as well.
But your family says that you
like to sing on road trips.
Is that true?
- That's very true.
Since we lived in Australia,
we took a lot of like,
long,
hour road trips.
Like we would take like
seven, eight hour road trips,
and I sang like a lot
of Taylor Swift, like,
Beyonce like songs, but I-
I really wanted to mention
that "Because of You"
was definitely a part of that playlist,
and I think it was on repeat.
I can sing it from top to bottom.
- Okay, I cannot wait
to tell my niece that,
'cause I'm so not cool to
her, but now I will be.
Thank you for that.
Thank you for the cred.
Well, congrats on your new song, man.
I love "On the Ground."
It is such a cool song.
How would you describe
your new music to everyone?
- I would say the song really
resonates with me, myself.
There's a part in the song that says,
"I've worked my whole
life just to get high,"
just to be like, "look at
me, I'm never coming down."
But it eventually says,
"But everything I need is on the ground."
And it's just a song that kind of
tries to keep everybody grounded.
- Yeah!
- Tries to tell everybody,
take a moment to sit back
and think about what really
matters, you know, to us.
- Absolutely! It's also
one hell of a vibe.
It's a really cool song.
I'm into it.
So, well when my staff found out
that you were going to
be here, they freaked.
Do you mind if one of my
producers asks you a question,
'cause she really wants to.
- Not at all! I'd love that!
- Okay, awesome!
Please, everybody welcome
senior associate producer,
Jasmine Stephen, everybody!
(Kelly imitates horn)
Give it up for Jasmine!
- Hi, Jasmine!
(Kelly laughs)
- So, Jasmine, you're a massive K-pop fan.
I did not know that, this is awesome.
- Absolutely! Like, I
have been known to, like,
call out of work just to fly
across the country to go see X.
I didn't do that here! I promise you!
But like, I've done it before.
- Well now we know where
you're going to be, Jasmine.
(Kelly laughs)
So what would you want to ask Rosé?
- So Rosé, as you know,
I'm a huge fan of yours,
but I love your puppy, Hank!
He is so cute!
So I just want to know,
what's his favorite food?
What's his favorite color?
And can I be his best friend?
And then additionally, if
I can be his best friend,
can I be his godparent?
(Kelly laughs)
- She is getting in there!
She wants it all, Rosé!
(Kelly laughs)
- Any time! I would love that!
I mean, Hank is like, the cutest puppy.
I adopted him. I actually-
So, in Korea, there's like
a bunch of people who upload
these, um, puppies
who are up for like, adoption,
and they kind of don't have a home.
And so I saw him online,
and this lovely lady was
kind of posting about him,
telling people to, you
know, adopt, not buy.
And I fell in love with him.
And he's just so adorable.
Like you said, he does, like,
he's very good with tricks.
If I say nose, he would go up and like,
poke his nose through my fingers.
And, uh-
His favorite food is, uh-
His favorite food? Just
any type of dog snack.
We give him, like, all these treats.
He just likes anything, to be honest.
Anything that's related to eating.
And, yeah.
His favorite color? I have no idea.
(Rosé laughs)
I'll ask him that!
- You'll have to ask.
Everybody, Rosé's-
I love that we're ending there, Rosé.
There's no segue.
Rosé's debut solo project is called "R,"
and her single is "On the Ground."
And it's an amazing song.
You got to check it out.
Both are actually out right now.